The Joe Rogan Experience you said you uh
you lost a lot of weight what did you do
in terms of your diet uh you know what I
was very consistent I was able to eat
you know and have a a plan like you know
I had breakfast I'd have lunch I'd have
dinner whereas before God I was always
on the road so it's like I never wanted
to eat before I went up on stage because
then it would mess with like I get
heartburn and you don't want to be
burping or farting in front of a crowd
so I wait until the end and then by the
time the show's over what's available to
eat you know it's terrible food terrible
and you're starving yes you can't wait
to eat yeah and then go to sleep and
then it was just that cycle repeat and
it just you know over the years man it
got good to me so I gained all that
weight so being home for a year
um you know I was having an actual
regular clean breakfast of you know
nothing crazy from the road it was all
food that was store-bought and preparing
my own food you can get like a meal prep
company that will make meals for you
that are like I've done work out yeah
I've done those in how that worked I was
into it for a couple couple weeks but
then it's like oh man I'm tired of
[__] broccoli broccoli
tired of this [__] yeah
uh what helped out a lot too was that
you know I was every day I was walking a
lot and you know I was lifting weights
three times a week well that's great and
then again going to see my doctors
getting on certain plans like um you
know I wear a monitor now for my sugar
you know so I'm always I'm able to keep
tabs on my sugar Wares before it was out
of control you know I was I was
averaging waking up at 400 which is like
you might just go to hospital normal you
want to be somewhere between 80 and 120
at least for me
and so yeah it was I was I was riding
the the what they say the the check
engine light on for too long
that's good and so uh you know and then
I got high blood pressure and of course
you know you don't know it until they
tell you or until you you know check
yourself so then getting on medication
for that getting on medication for
diabetes and you know
I'm sorry
you gotta get the bad babies and that
but uh getting my health in order with a
doctor and with the food and with the
working out whereas I wasn't able to do
that on the road
um
or I would make a lot more excuses
because I didn't you know also you want
to have energy for those shows and
sometimes when you work out really hard
after it's over you're so tired and when
you're really tired it's hard to like
fire back up to get ready for the shows
especially if it's a new thing you're
doing you know if your body's adapted to
it you could do it pretty easy but if
your body's not adapted to it like a
hard workout it's like what the [__] is
this and all my energy goes into the
shell so when I'm up there I'm hitting
it hitting it hitting it you know I'm
not sluggish I'm not standing still
right
I've seen your performance moves like
yeah but then when I get off them yeah
the thing is if you did get healthy and
you did get in shape it would really
genuinely help your ability to maintain
that because I mean just imagine if you
said you lost 70 pounds imagine if you
had to do your show right now with a 70
pound vest on oh gosh yeah I know yeah
it sucks and that's the reality of
weight yeah it's the reality of gravity
my knees my hips everything everything
breathing harder yeah I do workouts with
a 25 pound vest on and just a 25 pound
vest on just 25 pounds it's not even
that much like if you pick up 25 pounds
doesn't seem like much that 25 pound
vest makes a giant difference do
everything with that vest on and
everything's way harder Farmers carries
chin UPS push-ups dips body weight
squats everything's harder with just 25
pounds people gain and lose 25 pounds
like it's nothing but when you're
walking around with that 25 pounds on
that is just you're carrying that man
that's a lot of burden on your resources
your biological resources your issue
your bones your joints your hip your
back
you're you just fatigue you know and
then maybe the writing that you do maybe
writing would be sharper maybe you'd
have more that you were thinking about
if you had more pumping through your
body you know oh believe me it's it's I
I agree 100 with everything that you're
saying it's not even a an issue of not
knowing or not understanding or not
seeing the bigger picture Gonna Get You
On Adderall and ozempic nice let's go I
just got on those epic did you oh yeah I
want to hear something funny they uh I
got approached by ozempic early on
before they had the [__] song and uh
what's the song
it's based on that old song yeah oh it's
magic that's wrong yeah and so yeah they
approached me and they wanted me to be
their their spokesperson for ozempic
yeah and uh you know we took a meeting
and everything and I mean you know I
appreciated the fact that they actually
approached the diabetic to to be the
spokesperson diabetes medicine yeah I'm
gonna be the new woman Brimley you know
so uh it just it the deal didn't work
out but you're still doing it so you're
on it what's funny is I wasn't on it
when I took the meeting and you know it
wasn't like I said one 2020 hit and I
got went to go see my doctor he goes I'm
gonna put you on this thing called
ozempic I'm like are you freaking
kidding me I'm like I could have been
getting that [__] for free
but uh yeah so it's once I I you know
give myself a shot once a week some
people use it to lose weight you know
like like you know people that aren't
necessarily really big yes we'll use
that to you know suppress their appetite
and stuff like that because it will make
you uh a little nauseous
like in the mornings I wake up and I'm
like oh I gotta drink like a Shaker so
you only do it once a week when people
are on it for weight loss do they do it
like every day like how often they do it
don't know what the cycle is for using
ozempic for for weight loss
but I just know that when I first did it
I dropped 15 pounds like in God like a
week wow yeah so your body will react to
it immediately but then of course you
plateau and stuff like that they say
that it limits your appetite that's what
that's one of the bigger facts of it
yeah yeah I was I was waking up queasy
and so you know you feel a little
nauseous you're not really trying to
it's crazy because it's everywhere like
you see all these ads for it and even
like Tony Hinchcliffe brought this up
like CNN had a thing on it but it seems
like a story but it kind of is an ad you
know it's kind of an ad for ozempic but
it seems like it's a story about
Hollywood celebrities but really just
jazzing up the fact that everybody's
taking out zempic like it seems like
there's something more going on there
other than just just oh yeah yeah like
you're you probably got paid to do that
that story you know because I'm telling
you I take it every week and that
initial first hit of the weight loss
yeah it's true yeah but it doesn't it at
least it didn't continue for me how
often do people take ozempic when
they're trying to lose weight Jamie
it's like also you're tapering off I
think or yeah or maybe it gets high I
think maybe it's actually ramping up the
dosage you know like you start well
let's say like 0.25 units up to like one
but there's supposed to be a time where
you're supposed to get off of it right
uh as far as like for if you're trying
to cut weight with it I think they're
cut weight I suppose they're pushes like
a cycle like you're supposed to be like
10 12 weeks on probably 12 weeks off
this [__] are pushing that
right but it does help regulate my sugar
yeah so I do I between the Monitor
because my monitor is always checking my
sugar so
for example right now I don't have the
monitor with me
it's in the car because uh the honey
those honey honey spikes my sugar like
like nothing sure but because my voice
is a little off right now so I'm taking
the honey yeah
um so do you watch Like Sugar like bread
you start you cut that stuff out after a
while you start knowing exactly what
does what so you already know like ah I
can eat that I shouldn't and then you
know you you see things and you're like
all right this is gonna set it off so I
also have my I take a insulin oh okay
so I'm trying to I play that game how
long you've been doing that
oh God over five years for sure so is
this type 2 diabetes yes so that's the
type that you can reverse with uh diet
and exercise yes yeah
and again it's not for lack of knowing I
already know I get it bro and that's
what sucks it's like I feel like
everything that I've ever attempted to
do for my career
I've been able to do but I for myself my
personal self losing weight's been the
hardest thing the hardest [__] thing
in the world